私は初め車窓
話を読みください
ん
私はじめシャツを
1本
伝えとは
思っておりますか
まだ当分はう
てきそうにはありません
私弾み殺音を
磯ほしいです
結構がっつり
結構月忙しいです
本日をもちまして
動画を
止めさせていただきます
毎日出す
感じねっ
ねっ
予選ものはでねください
ちょっと真面目な感じでバージョンって言ったんですけど結構何がっちんの話をさせて
いただきましょう
あの正直まさにと毎日登校も無理です絶対に出来ませんあんまりスを知ら b で書籍
したくないんですけどもあの忙しすぎて絶対無理ながいろいろスタッフを雇ったり編集
色などによってまったりしたんですけども無理です
絶対無理100%埋まりもう無理なは絶対無理ということが今年はっきりわかりました
ということですねあの僕毎日当コーナーで1回も一言もいったことないんですけども
なんか毎日出すような空気出してる給油中バーだったんですよ
なんか夜になると今日はメインチャンネル動画ありますかといういただいててほんと
杏里がありがとうございます
ないですで結構咲い疑問
ですね毎日動画ですのもう無理で中休みながら結構やってたんですけどもあの
もっと頻度減らそうかなと思いましてあの値段か自分の首絞めだみたいになってるん
ですけどもメインもセカンドチャンネルも畑もやってるとねあの本当にヤバイです
畑下に関しては畑の人たちで編集したり僕が叩けないぞ編集するわけじゃないんで
そんなにアレなんですけども
出演道に出ないといけないんだ
ついに結構長い撮影た方の時間がとられてなんか最近だと正直
ぶっちゃけて言うよメインチャンネルがほぼおまけみたいな感じになって言って撮影が
畑で撮影とかなんかいろいろチェックしたり人数が多いんでミーティングしたりして
時間取られてああーーやべきょうの目にどんな客て急いで帰ってきてなんかアセアセと
なんかとりあえず撮っとこみたいな感じのメイン
正直今年自然全部そうでしたうちのお母ちゃんからあんた案件動画の方が面白いって
言われるぐらいです
否めん辞め
ん
不安言動がねいろんな人の協力してもらったりしてで栗で高いんで何か僕はでねそんな
気はしてましてあでおりひょっとして案件だーのほうが面白いんじゃねっていうような
動画も結構あったりしてそれはそれでいいんですよねそれ素敵なことですけども
ってそうじゃないんだと
がいろいろ初心に帰ると僕別に毎日動画だしたいわけじゃなくて大揃い動画されたせれ
ばいいのかなと思いましてあのすいませんまあ2020年もそんな感じで行くと思い
ます動画の頻度本当に落としますヒカキンさんとかもう再現を話したんですけどもう
あの人が思うんで確か1週間に23本も出してないくらいのケースでやられている
おっしゃいましたあなたも結構も毎日と完全に止めてる彼のスタイルでやってるんで
ヒカキンさんはなんかテレビとかめっちゃでてるからなあこれが違うんだよな
サボってるわけじゃないんですよ私もちゃんと見なきゃいけないして畑下の動画に見て
なきゃいけないしサブチャンネルもやんなきゃいけないさっきんだか変星人に教え
なきゃいけないのがお金の管理やらあったり東京行くことがあったり東京行く時の
スケジュールも最近3日
入ったんですけどスケジュールこれで書をご覧下さい女の隙を縫ってボケ動画の日撮影
したり表示したりしなきゃいけなくて
もう
正直に言いますあまり急がずアピスわけないんですけども本当に
無理信者というですねあの1年だったなと思います
すごい楽しいせよ楽しいし土としていいけどなんか毎日動画出さなきゃっていうアセ
アセしてる感じが
ちょっと
本当にこれでいいのかなということでいろんな人と話し合ったりしたんですけども
今後は本当にもうしませんなんかなんか言ってると思ってこういうことない子だします
みたいなこと言ってますけどあの子が勝ちです今後の動画まあをもそれがどうかわかん
ないんですけども
僕が本当にやりたいことこれぞ肇社長っていう動画を出せるようにあの頑張っていき
たい
思います姉昔のようにはいかんのですよ大学生の時とかも何にも考えてなかったし
東京行く機会もそんななかったしもう全然に動画だけ作ってヘラヘラしてれば良かった
んですけど僕は決して要領のいい人間じゃないので東京行って動画以外の仕事を
しっかりこなして気が毎日ヘラヘラ笑ってどんどん出せるほど尿量を僕にはありません
でした皆にやれって言ってるわけじゃないんですけど
このレベルの生活をこなせる人僕いないと思っています正直はいというわけで
あの夫皆
悲しい可愛いしないで9位なぜ事は何もないぞメインチャンネル品の没を減るんです
けども
畑はしっかりと今後とも頑張らせていただきますそしてはじめたちを2のゲーム実況の
方もちょっとしっかりやっていきたいなと思っております
もう2にかしたら今年普通にやばかったからねもう12週間動画足さない時とかあった
から稼働できないですよもうサブチャンネルなんて
という受けて今後の名
チャンネルの方向性は
1本入庫んです動画週間のがトランク魂の心配しないでください
僕は元気に動画を撮っておりますあのねぇ
難しいような今なんか芸能人もめざ草 youtube に来てるじゃないですか
ユーチューバーになることが目標じゃなくてユーチューバーになってから何かをするっ
ていうのがめっちゃ広がっていくと僕を持っておりまして
服とかもそうですよね結構テレビとか出たり今年はシームをあの何回か出させて
いただいたりしたんですけどとてもいろんなことをさせて頂いた1年でしたが
そので学ぶことも多かったです動画以外で誰だ
あの僕は結局はどんなことをしてても動画を作るの時が一番好きでかといって時間内
なら接するとこう
アセアセしながら動画を作るのも嫌でやっぱり自分の鳥大動画を時間をかけて作るのが
今の僕の生活には一番合ってるのかなと思っております
なぜねー
悲しまないでまでも全然道があったら出すと思うんでひょっとしたら毎日出たりするか
もしれないんですけども
もう無理だな普通に限界だけでこれから動画一本ずで本気で頑張るんで夫と今まで
頑張ってなかった d たいわけではないんですけども出せなきゃいけないっていう
感じでちょっと気を抜くだかもしれないね
1本だけホンギ動画作っていきたいと思いますねあのぜひ皆さん
ああああああ
と箱ごとも見てください
じゃん
ジャミラしたローソンの店長どこかでやります
[音楽]